after last week's hearings the FBI
opened an investigation into Cavanaugh
that's a big deal yeah I'm glad they did
okay well that's our cue card woman Dana
it doesn't usually speak but this is
Dana do you think let's talk about this
we should talk about it do you think the
FBI is gonna get to the bottom of these
allegations against Kavanaugh oh of
course they will when I was in college
there were a lot of guys who acted like
Brett Kavanaugh and they all got what
was coming to them okay well some people
say Cavanaugh's actions were just normal
male behavior you know boys will be boys
yeah some people did say that and you
know for the rest of us just calves just
as Cavanaugh left a lasting impression
yeah
well showing a lot of different sides of
himself so many different sides of
himself okay obviously let's be clear
this has been a stressful time for you
it has Conan how are you how you
handling it well with lots of positive
thinking plenty of self-care and
commiserating with friends sorry
[Applause]
and commiserating with friends okay wait
a minute
I'm yeah that's it tilt that card
forward I mean I told you vodka I'm not
telling you to do that I'm suggesting it
it's your choice whether you actually do
it or not wait a minute
I just realized we're in a sketch and
I'm gonna read that wait a minute you're
in a coven oh we call our book club okay
Dana I just want to say that like you
I'm tired really tired of seeing
powerful privilege men getting away with
treating women badly Thank You Conan I
also I just mean maybe if we took the
time to listen to women I mean really
listen we'd be better off yeah thank you
for saying that
and I really a listening could inspire
more women to have the courage to speak
truth to power do you feel inspired now
Dana
James to cars everybody
you